das hier sind echte Spaghetti Carbonara
und die sind ein absoluter Game changer
und dafür braucht man nur guantade
Pecorino Eigelb Spaghetti mehr nicht vor
allem keine Sahne und wir kochen unsere
Nudeln ein bisschen dumm den große
Würfel geschnitten damit wir quasi so
ein garverlauf in der Mitte haben und
wir lassen ihn aus schaut euch das mal
an und jetzt guckt mal wie viel davon
Fett ist das alles ist aus unserer
rausgekommen und natürlich werden wir
das nicht weg tun unsere golden schade
zur Seite diesen Pecorino reiben wir
jetzt jetzt nehmen wir uns vier Eigelb
und vermischen die mit unserem Pecorino
bisschen mehr Pecorino jetzt geben wir
Nudelwasser dazu und rühren
kontinuierlich merkt schon direkt die
Flüssigkeit arbeitet jetzt beginnen wir
mit unserem Fett zu emulgieren bis es
dann ungefähr so aussieht Pfeffer rein
Salz brauchen wir keins bei der großen
Mengen Schale und jetzt nehmen wir
unsere Nudeln hinzu und rühren die
direkt unter damit unsere Soße nicht
stocken
seht ihr diese perfekte Soße anrichten